Oh
[Music]
welcome to console info these are some
shows that I'm gonna be making that go a
little bit more in-depth on how to
improve your JavaScript skills on
today's episode I'm going to talk about
how to add es lint to your JavaScript
project
yes lint is a great tool for making sure
that your JavaScript code is healthy and
free of any errors that a machine
otherwise catch for you the analogy that
I have to make is that es lint provides
nice guardrails while you walk along the
tightrope that is JavaScript so to start
things off I'm going to make a new
project that will code together with so
we're new maker ES lint demo CD has link
demo and let's go into our code editor
for that you're welcome to code along
with me if you want or just let me do
all the work the first thing that I'm
going to do is initialize a new node
project with NPM in it it's got to meet
some questions I'm gonna say yes yes
good great
perfect love it yes sweets so the first
thing I'm going to do we have them here
let's just in a repo I would like to do
this just so I can keep track of the
progress that I've made in a product in
a project so I get add dot get Styles
get commit I'll do the knit commit cool
so let's make a file that we're gonna
actually code in and we have this index
J s file and what should we have it do
I'm just gonna have it say I like logs
five times how about that so we're going
to say Const message equals I like logs
and we are going to then what we have to
do how do
[Music]
just make it for that I guess
so for index let's do I is less than
five and we're gonna say a console log
message cool so if we run this node
index great because I didn't save it
cool I like lots let's actually make
this show message do this here sweet so
cool so we have a simple project that we
can use and everything looks fine but
let's actually add something a little
bit weird so let's just make like you
know did show message and we're just a
equals false okay and that looks fine
but you'll see wyman add us in a second
so this is cool let's commit this so you
know initial work initial work that's a
hard word to spell gotta add it cool so
the first thing you can do when you're
adding eslint this is the fun part of
the demonstration is npm install saved
IES limbs and you're going to save as
lint as a dev dependency because the
dependencies are things that are in your
project that aren't required for
production usages linting is an example
of that where you can lint something but
doesn't really need to be passing lint
to actually work in production so for
that case or install es lint and there's
a jeopardy theme song playing somewhere
cool done and there's a lot on fact that
ye eslint actually comes with a built in
way of initializing itself so we can
actually do is go in and do in it and
here we're presented with some questions
how would you have to figure guess
Lynn's answer questions about your style
use a popular style guide and inspect
your java files I'm actually just how to
ask you some questions
so amazing Eknath script six features
yes sure are using modules no because
this is a common jazz project
with node my Nicole only ran in the in
node not the browser so I can do that I
did not use JSX I used spaces I use
single Unix
yes what format do you want your
favorite call to be in let's just do
JSON sweet so now if you check here to
get status you can see that my package
JSON file has been modified as well as
my es lint our C file has been created
if you hop in here you can see some
basic things are in here this is really
cool and this is this is the part that I
find most beneficial is that by default
is lint has built in recommendation
built in recommended rules and here you
can actually see them being extend this
that you get all those base rules for
free and then here you have places that
are being overwritten and this to begin
a project is more than fine this is a
great beginning to make sure that you
have started lynching your code that
there's no arena's errors that might be
in there that I look harder to catch so
if you actually back into index we
actually see that we have some things
are being yelled at so what is this
expected annotation of four spaces so
this is a place where I'm like no
insolence I actually want two spaces so
if we go here indent will actually
change this to two see if it and there
we go
that error went away and this is where I
think the real power of the islets comes
in because this is a pretty you know
contrived example but what you see here
is that did show message is assigned a
value but never used and I've seen this
a lot in my code or the people code
where you are working on some software
and you make some variables and you keep
working on it and you forget that you
made those variables and they just kind
of stick around there and they're not me
in any way
and yes lint is because it can
statically analyze your code tell you
about these things and this is the
example of that happening so let me
actually delete that so there's no
longer there and here's another one
unexpected console statement and that's
usually good you shouldn't want to
actually have console log statements in
your code is usually a sign that you're
debugging
we want that before Hewes cases out you
want to keep that so here's another
little thing that you can do with yes
lint you actually just say as a comment
to disable EF lint for a rule he is
leant to save old
nextline disabled and i'll Tibet anymore
however I'm not a big fan of these
blanket disabling statements so what you
should actually do my trick is like undo
it and I see that the rule here is no
console that is the es Lynch rule and
that is the only rule that I want to
disable for the next line so if I do no
console that goes away because if I had
just so now I've had sleep the semicolon
you just hit that the error comes back
because this is now a different rule
that it's complaining about semi if I
had just done es Lynch still next line
like that that wouldn't VidCon which is
why you want to actually explicitly call
out the rules that you're disabling when
you're doing this features let's go back
do that
save it cool and now let's add some
command line usages for this as well so
that you don't have to rely on just your
editor for es lending so I'll go to
package JSON we're gonna say lint and
when I say es lint where you can
reference the node module from here
directly we don't to go into node
modules for that and then I forgot the
signature for this lesson you npm run
lint I want it to be a file so if I just
do that does that work
let's go back and actually get this
airing out to make sure oh this is cool
so now if I do npm run lint there we go
we have our air successive being ran so
i add back that disabled line save it
and run this again I am lint free so
that was a quick introduction to how to
add es linking to your project this is
probably the dead simple way to get
started there are many more richer
default es lint configuration files used
on the Internet the big one is Airbnb
which you
I've heard it before they have a huge
guide and styles they try to fall but I
think that might be a bit too
heavy-handed to get started having just
the basic iya Slynt recommended files
then going on to the website for years
learnt to see things you want to change
up will get you at least on a good solid
foundation so that is es lint hopefully
eventually new it's very easy to get up
and sorted with es lint and look forward
to the next episode where I teach you
something else that's new see you then